good morning everybody and welcome to
episode number eight of my GE only
challenge uh just to get this started I
will be doing the giveaway in this
episode so stick around to the end and I
will be giving away the 10 mil cash
prize uh to one of the commenters on my
last video now for the plan for this
episode um I going to be unlocking the
construction skill I am pretty much at
10 mil right now I'm going to do a
little bit of flipping so I'm not
starting again from nothing uh but I'm
not going to go all the way till 15 or
20 I'm starting to get impatient and I
want to unlock construction so I can
start getting that leveled up as well as
my farming skill which has been stuck at
like s or eight for a long time and now
that I have uh my home unlocked I'll be
able to uh use bagged plants in my home
and level my farming up quickly and then
I can start planting stuff in the tree
patch the next major goal is going to be
getting to 750 total level so I can go
in the sewer and start training on the
monsters there so now that I have the
two extra skills I should be able toit
hit it uh I don't think I'll have to buy
herblore to get that uh it's only going
to be about 40 in construction and
farming as well as a couple extra levels
in some of my other skills so I'm going
to focus on getting some of my lower
level skills leveled up and maybe we'll
try to get 260 wood cutting uh just so
we can well cut some U trees I don't
think they'll be that good but we'll
give them a try all right hope you guys
enjoy and let's get started and to start
things off I have a flip of the Obsidian
Shield or The Tucket skill uh looks like
I'm I made about 400k on this so
9445 and I bought them all for 9 mil so
445k which is going to put us almost
precisely at 10 mil I need to sell
something in my bank so I can get that
uh green cash stack we'll withdraw some
random stuff okay there we go we just
sold off some random stuff so now we are
at 10 mil so we can afford uh the
construction skill uh but first of all I
need to get a little bit more than this
cuz starting right from like zero GP
again is going to be pretty annoying so
I'm going to go and flip a couple maybe
try of the Seas uh pretty quick item to
flip uh what is very confusing about
this though is I actually profited when
I checked the margin I profited 40K
somehow uh so I had to go check that
again uh but yeah look bought it for
1196 and sold it for 12242 weird uh so
we did end up selling the Trident pretty
quickly uh we got actually a 57k profit
on each one which is really good uh
342k in total off of a very quick flip
as always nice unfortunately we hit the
buy limit for this but that's still
going to get us an extra 350k okay we're
taking a quick break from flipping and
leveling up our wood cutting skill uh
it's actually going pretty quick we're
up to 35 to 40K an hour uh just from oak
trees which is actually really good uh
there is level 56 wood cutting uh we're
going to try to hit 60 this episode and
then we can give you trees a try and see
how slow they are okay we got another
Genie lamp that's awesome uh we're
slowly working towards our first
thieving level can't really think of
anything else to put in yet there's
another 10 thie experience we're halfway
to level okay we're just about to hit
another wood cutting level uh and uh we
did not get another Genie lamp yet
unfortunately but there is 57 wood
cutting and uh we can make a Waka canoe
still on the wood cutting grind but
actually got another clue scroll Nest uh
so I just kind of thought of another
goal I could set for this account is to
get one of every clue scroll even though
I cannot do them but I can get them in
Nest so that'll be kind of interesting I
have a medium one already and there's an
easy one uh that's two of them already
and also 58 wood cutting and there is
level 59 wood cutting I also got another
Genie lamp which is awesome right into
thieving I think I only need three or
four more of these so that's getting
pretty nice ooh and a magic seed from
one of my nests that is like 12 130k
actually that's really good all right
we're just about to hit 60 wood cutting
what is that guy doing get out my turf
bro uh we're just about to hit H 60 wood
cutting there we go now I can cut the U
trees although I think I should wait to
get the dragon axe uh either way I think
U are exceedingly slow but I'll give
them a try just to see yeah this is
brutally slow with the Rune Axe and just
kind of in general but they are very AFK
so even if I could get uh 30k wood K
experience an hour I would definitely do
it just because they are very AFK more
for the wood K experience then for the
money but I guess a little money always
is nice okay and I think I'm just going
to go ahead and train up my fir making a
little bit uh very easy skill but was a
bit lower level than I would have liked
uh we're just doing Maple logs right now
and that is going going to be 55 fir
making still going extremely quickly but
I think I'm going to stick with Maple
logs cuz mahogany are going to cost a
bit and maple logs are only a little bit
worse experience per hour and only costs
about six coins each and we're about to
have another crafting level come in I'm
still on uh the orbs probably going to
be doing this for quite a while until I
become very wealthy uh cuz right now
it's very cheap crafting experience and
there's no way we're really way to get
that but uh this is going to be uh 62
crafting uh which is pretty good I'm not
sure what my actual goal would be uh but
62 is good for now I can make the fire
battle staff okay I have quite a few
flips coming in so I'll go ahead and
break it down for you most of these
flips are the darkness Set uh but I did
flip one of the or 10 of the obsidian
Shields again uh only for about a 100K
profit so not too bad there the hood of
Darkness was really good I got a 472k
profit on that item uh the Rope top I
got
333k on and the uh glove is not much
only a 50k profit there okay and I went
ahead and just put in some other flips
dragon halberg Dragon Battle Axe ancient
page 4 and more gloves of
Darkness okay once again while we're
waiting for the flips to come through
I'm just going to go do some crafting
there is 63 crafting just from the Molen
glass now I can craft green Dragonite
armor I want to become super rich I can
go ahead and do that for now just going
to do the owered orbs so everything kind
of sucked except for the gloves of
Darkness I got no profit on the dragon
hird and no profit on the Dragon Battle
uh just about 105k on the ancient page 4
uh but the gloves of Darkness I got a
550k profit I'm making a 55k profit per
glove and 10 gloves I'm making over 500k
in profit uh which is really awesome
that'll bring our cash stack uh past the
11 mil Mark and we're getting pretty
close I think I'm going to shoot for 13
mil or something like that before I go
ahead and buy the construction skill so
another amazing flip coming through
through and that is the Mystic smoke
staff so I ended up buying them for 20
28k each and I sold them for uh 2210 so
about a 200k profit and I flipped five
of them uh so about a 910k profit just
off of uh the Mystic smoke staff which
is amazing so a couple quick flips
coming through uh the armal chaps ended
up just dumping uh for the price I
bought them for uh Fury ornament kits
only got about a 60k margin on each one
so 120k there and the new Crystal Shield
did have a good margin but I only
managed to buy one of them uh for about
110k profit would have been really nice
if I managed to buy 10 of those or
something another really huge flip
coming through of the Dragon Sword
actually I bought them for 11358 and
sold them for
12132 uh which is about a 800 roughly K
profit on just the dragon sword and I
think that's going to be enough money uh
to just go ahead and uh well unlock the
construction skill so this is going to
be a giveaway once again the information
or the winner will be announced at the
end of the episode but for now this
money is just going to go into my ALT
account until I declare a winner uh so
that's exciting I can now go ahead and
get my house and start training
construction okay I'm at the housing
estate agent give me my house man I've
been waiting for this for quite a while
uh it's only 10K oh only 1,000 coins wow
what a steal of a deal I will take your
starter house thank you very much much
and there we go now I have a house
unlocked I have to go buy a bunch of
teleports and rings of wealth okay so
let's buy 100 uh home teleport or house
teleport tablet as well as 10 rings of
wellth to start with it's going to get a
little pricey teleporting back and forth
uh because I have to go back to the gr
chain so I have to use a ring of walth
there's no other way to get back uh but
this is what how I'm going to do it
anyway break a tab uh and go to my home
there we go uh completely blank start
our home nice and uh when I want to
leave I'll just have to use the Ring of
wealth and teleport back to the Grand
exchange now I'm going to probably
forget a ring of wealth at some point so
I have to figure out a backup plan okay
these bag tree plants took a long time
to buy but finally we got 50 of them uh
it's not a very common method of
training but actually seems pretty good
uh getting a bunch of early construction
levels and farming levels are two skills
that are a little expensive and lengthy
to level up in the beginning uh well
especially farming you have to wait on
trees to grow but for this you literally
just put something in the ground dig it
up plant it right again and you can
train farming uh like you can train
crafting uh you just need a watering can
and some of the bagged tree plants okay
we're just about to construct the Garden
in my home uh we'll put it like uh well
that's fine okay there's level eight
farming uh again like I said really easy
just put the plant in the ground uh say
remove plant there we go put another
plant in the ground and there is another
uh 31 crafting and construction
experience giving us our first
Construction level as well as eight
farming there is level 10 farming uh
going very quickly it can now make
Redberry bushes as well as level five
construction uh I can now build a
kitchen there is level eight
construction but more importantly there
is going to be another farming level
pretty soon here there is level 12
farming and that is going to mean I can
do a plus three boost to be able to
plant an oak tree finally be able to use
that farming patcho there no more raking
those stupid leaves all right there we
go there is level 10 construction
actually getting a decent of
construction experience off of these uh
bag Plants alone uh they're a little
pricey though I mean I paid them 1.9k
each uh but I'm not going to have to do
this for much longer there we go I
finally can plant an oak sapling after
all this time I just have to eat a
garden pie to give me a plus three boost
to 15 and put the super compost in as
well as the oak sapling finally have
something nice to look at and one or 2K
uh farming experience I get once that's
grown uh so pretty nice okay I'm on to
building just book cases uh there is 11
construction for now I'm probably going
to do bookcases all the way until 30
roughly then I might move on to
something else uh but one thing I just
realized is I don't have access to a
butler which is probably going to slow
things down a bit another Construction
level coming in as well okay there is
level 15 construction and now I can have
a four room house if I were to ever so
want one which I will eventually okay
I'm just put that level 17 and this is a
kind of a noteworthy level because I can
move on to making um all this wooden
features or all these wooden furniture
pieces at a workbench uh which will
actually Quicken the process a little
bit uh but I need to build a workshop
first but I have no coins okay I'm back
with coins and now I can build the
workshop uh which allows you to build
the workbench now what this does is
allow you to make furniture furniture
packs uh which will be a little bit
quicker okay there's level 20
construction just off making these
Furniture packs on top of being quicker
and not having to go into building mode
to make them you can also sell them uh
so a little bit of your money is back I
guess if you want to count that okay
just H 25 construction off of bookcases
uh still going pretty quick and the
workbench does help a lot you don't have
to go into building mode I can literally
just run in here start working at the
workbench and I don't have to
deconstruct the item as well which does
save quite a bit of
time okay just a couple quick flips
coming through but I think that's pretty
much where we're going to end it for
today guys uh well the briefcase I got
about 170k on so not bad and the uh miss
battle sta about 100K uh so we're
working our way up there and yeah so
let's go have a quick look at all the
progress I made this episode uh so as
far as cash I have well only 125k cash
uh but that being said I do have an
offer in the grand exchange right now uh
so in the grand exchange I put a 3 mil
offer in so we're sitting at about 3 mil
in cash now as far as my skills go I
have leveled up my construction all the
way to level 28 uh farming to 13 for now
uh other no levels are my wood cutting I
got to 60 uh which is pretty nice uh I
got five fir making levels or at least
got to 55 anyway and anything else
really noteworthy and a couple crafting
levels as well all the way to 63 so uh
the total level is sitting at 677 right
now so only about 85 more total levels
than I can unlock uh the SE system uh
for better training and just a little
more room uh to play around in okay guys
so now what a lot of you guys have been
waiting for in the last episode because
I was hitting well 10K subscribers and I
hit 10 mil in the series and I can't
have it on the account anymore I decided
just to do a giveaway uh so this is
going to be for the winner of the 10 mil
from people who commented on the last
episode so good luck everyone and let's
start pick a winner and uh raffling off
using this uh random comment picker
website but the winner is going to be
era RSN I'd like to win because I just
dumped about 10 mil into construction
myself and would like to F fill in the
Gap uh for your bank all right
congratulations to era thanks again for
everyone who participated and left a
comment and uh just continue watching
the series so thanks a lot for checking
out episode 8 and I'll see you guys in
the next episode
[Music]
n